this is a production of cornell
university
perfect thank you very much so thank you
very much for for being here today
um i am dr daniela herrgara i'm the
emerging crop specialist um
which as mary was saying it's a new um
position at the cornell cooperative
extension
i've been a cannabis researcher for a
while
um
this is my email
my website if you want to contact me
and um
i am going to be talking about
my experience so what i did mostly
research at the university of colorado
in boulder uh before joining the cornell
cooperative extension i am also the
co-founder of the cannabis genomic
research initiative which is our group
at cu boulder
and the founder and director of the
agricultural genomics foundation that
it's a 501c3 nonprofit that aims to
bring
cannabis scientific findings to a broad
public
and so i'm going to be talking about the
things that i did the things that i'm
doing and the things that i would like
to do in the future
so
for those of you who were at this
meeting a it's a a meet-up that we that
i am co-organizing with some people in
the industry here in new york state this
is happening the second thursday of
every month
uh for those of you who were part of
that i did i gave a very similar
presentation that day so um
i am sorry if you were there as well
so uh i graduated from my phd in 2013 at
indiana university bloomington where i
studied host and parasite co-evolution
i was thinking a lot about
why would individuals reproduce sexually
instead of cloning themselves
um and
one of the reasons why you would like um
sexual reproduction instead of clonal
reproduction would be to if a to avoid
disease and parasitism particularly when
you have a very um
taxing disease
so i was thinking about how co-hosts and
parasites evolved i might my degrees in
evolutionary biology
and uh this is my advisor kurt lively at
cu at indiana university in bloomington
and so
when i finished my phd in 2013 i moved
to colorado
um i was going to work with nolan kane
so he is my postdoc advisor
and he was coming from a different side
of evolutionary biology thinking about
genomics so genomics is the entire
conglomerate of dna of genetic material
of organisms
and he was working with sunflowers
so yeah so that's what he did in
sunflowers was look at the entire genome
uh of sunflowers so i joined his lab and
i was gonna work with sunflowers
um but around that same time they were
legalizing a
cannabis or marijuana recreational use
in 2014
so i started working in cannabis instead
and one of the things that really caught
my attention was that cannabis
reproduces both
sexually and asexually and i was
thinking about those things through my
phd so clonal reproduction and so
cannabis has hermaphrodites and has um
individuals that are males and females
so it has dioecious and monitors
monitious individuals so that was really
what caught my attention when i started
working in cannabis back in 2013
and again cannabis is part of the family
cannabis
um along with hops so hops is its
closest um existing species they
diverged approximately 25 million years
ago
and so they are part of the same
family and again hops is one of the main
ingredients of beer
um and they are angiosperms so they are
plants that produce flowers
and what i did mostly was study the
genome so study the dna and the genes
uh in cannabis so the whole conglomerate
of dna of letters of the dna in an
organism so by definition what i was
doing was working with big data and
mostly bioinformatics
um
and one of the reasons why
um i was interested in this uh genomics
is because
you can draw parallels to how the plant
looks so you can draw parallels between
the genotype the genetic material and
the phenotype the physical
characteristics so the genotype the dna
and the phenotype the physical
characteristics of the plant
and one of the things that i did was to
look at the genes that are related to
cannabinoid production there are
multiple multiple cannabinoids here i'm
showing two which are of great
importance because they are the drivers
of this multi-billion dollar industry
however there's many many cannabinoids
and i also worked with some of them as
well
and uh i was part of a lot of different
publications that we um that uh for my
research while i was there at cu boulder
um in 2017 for example we published this
paper where we looked at the
cannabinoids the the um six different
cannabinoids from the cannabis produced
by the federal government
so i'm not sure if some of you um maybe
know that
in order for
research to be conducted in cannabis
because it's a schedule one
drug
um we must use the cannabis produced by
the federal government by the national
institute and drug abuse nida
and so we were able to get a hold of the
values of chemotypes for different um
cannabinoids produced by naida and i
want to show you a picture so we had we
got a hold of cannabinoids values for
the commercial marijuana that is
produced by the
private markets and by the government
and this is how it looks
so in this graph what i'm showing in the
y-axis which is the vertical axis is the
percent cannabinoids between um
different locations we had four
different locations for the private
market denver oakland sacramento and
seattle and we had uh nida the national
institute on drug abuse and nida differs
um in cbd and thc is the one that has
the lowest values
and when you look at the entire
cannabinoid production
um with this other statistical test
which is called the principal component
analysis that allows us to look at the
entire cannabinoid diversity
we can see that this diversity can be
partitioned into groups this think group
and this great group
and nida is only part of one of the
groups
and then when we look at this uh
diversity by location
oakland and sacramento they
contain nida's kind of cannabinoid
variation but naida does not contain
oakland and sacramento variation
then in 2021 so last year we got another
paper published regarding the genome of
these nida's varieties so i like to
think about it like in 2017 we looked at
the phenotype of the physical
characteristics and then in 2021 we
looked at the um at the genotype so at
the at the uh at the genome of these
very these varieties which were very um
i'm not gonna go into into details but
it was
very uh limited the amount of genetic
diversity
so
this is very important because
most medical um
studies are used using the
governmentally produced cannabis
and this review paper in 2018 found that
cannabis is only useful for three
different conditions pain in adults a
chemotherapy induced nausea and
spasticity in multiple sclerosis
and perhaps they only found that
cannabis is useful for three conditions
because they are using
a source that has limited diversity both
in the physical characteristics in the
in the cannabinoids and in the genome so
they're not using
the cannabis that people regularly use
in private markets
um and again this is how
the medical marijuana from private
markets looks versus the one that is
produced by the government
i also worked with hops a little bit so
i was part of the assembly of the
chloroplast genome so the chloroplast is
this organ in the plant um really
important organ for photosynthesis and
it has a genome of its own and basically
what we did is that we pieced so we we
we pieced the genome together and this
was actually my first paper in cannabis
in 2015
and i also work with hops and cannabis
while describing the cannabinoid genes
um i'm not gonna go again into detail
but i'm happy to talk to you about it if
you are curious about it but part of
this research while looking at the
cannabinoid genes in cannabis and i use
similar genes in hops this was published
in 2019.
um i was part of different um
private companies
steep hill which is a testing facility
and they have testing facilities all
over the u.s so i was part of their team
and then i was part of the front range
biosciences team so these companies
would fund me found my research at cu
boulder
with data provided by steep hill we
published this paper from
from nida that i just showed you and
then in 2020 we had another
statistical analysis where we
used machine learning to look at
different cannabinoids and the missing
values of different cannabinoids
and also in 2021 i was part of this
study where we looked at the different
physical characteristics of
traits that are important for the
industry i am going to be talking about
this particular paper on this um
seminars that are organized between usda
and cornell and my talk is on 420 so i
hope that i see you there as well
and i also started a non-profit
organization the agricultural genomics
foundation that aims in bringing
cannabis knowledge to a broad public uh
through agf we have a podcast cannabis
science today i highly recommend it and
we also have a class modern cannabis
science that is um
taught at cu boulder and it's open to
the public because it's taught through
continuing education
so i made a lot of professional
um relationships uh during my time in in
colorado
and personal relationships as well
and then i moved here to new york uh in
october i started this position at the
cornell cooperative extension
um i am starting to get to know a bunch
of people in the industry which is
really exciting and as time passes i
hope that this uh slide gets busier and
busier with multiple other companies one
of my tasks right now is to work on an
introduction a
manual a ham production manual and uh
this has been a very collaborative work
in the um survey that i'm going to put a
link or or mary or janice are going to
put a link in the in the
in the chat um we hope to have people
join us with this endeavor so if you
want to be part of it please um give us
our email give us your email in the in
the survey
and my idea is to build a cannabis
community here in new york state and to
establish myself as kind of the
middleman between the industry and
researchers and to develop research and
outreach programs that are going to
serve the community and help this
nascent industry thrive
uh again
all of this is a collaborative endeavor
um with the manual and also with other
uh things that we're going to be
developing in the future and i would
like to be part of building this
industry and answer many questions
together
i think that there will be room for
multiple businesses within the industry
not everyone has to be a grower or a
producer and there will be multiple
there will be plenty of room for
ancillary businesses
and we are all learning how to process
cannabis together so that's something
that we are um in this together and
again this is my email my website and
with that i will answer questions if you
have any questions thank you
all right today we're going to talk
about hemp micropropagation
originally this was supposed to be a
live how-to demonstration
however due to the covet related issues
this is going to be a powerpoint
presentation
so let me begin
i'm stationed at cornell university
satellite location the long island
horticultural research and extension
center in riverhead
this year we are celebrating
our 100th anniversary and i want to
invite you down for plant science day on
september 15th
before i begin to speak about
hemp micropropagation i want to take a
few seconds just to tell you a little
bit about our center
we are located in the heart of suffolk
county's agricultural industry
we are the only horticulture research
center in the united states that has
professional scientists who represent
each of the horticultural commodities
floriculture and greenhouses fruits and
viticulture vegetables and woody
ornamentals and landscape plants
in addition we have specialists for the
cross disciplines too we have two plant
pathologists a weed scientist and two
entomologists i represent the discipline
of plant tissue culture that we're going
to discuss today
our research center is located down at
the east end of long island it is a
little more than 300 miles from ithaca
it's a long drive but if you get a
chance to visit you will be surprised at
the beauty of eastern long island and
the amount of plant agriculture
due to our unique maritime climate good
soils high sunlight and other
environmental factors we are still the
number one county for greenhouses in new
york as well as ornamental nurseries we
have more than 2 000 acres of grapes and
grow more than 100 different kinds of
vegetables
okay that's the end of my short little
commercial for our anniversary
we're here today to discuss about plant
tissue culture and more specifically
plant micro propagation
plant tissue culture is the growth of
plants on a sterile nutrient medium in
vitro under controlled environmental
conditions
there are several uses for plant tissue
culture it can be used for plant
breeding disease elimination basic
research nutritional studies and much
more
today we are focusing on the applied
technique of micropropagation
plant micropropagation is one use for
plant tissue culture this technique is
used specifically for the clonal
propagation of plants in vitro
this is a photo of our lab on long
island we also have a micropropagation
lab on campus in ithaca
basically you need to have a location to
prepare media autoclave it
laminar airflow hoods to transfer plants
and growth chambers or light racks to
grow plants
everything that you see here you would
also see in a commercial laboratory
why is there such interest in using
plant micro propagation for him
the main reason that micropropagation is
popular is that it is a rapid procedure
to asexually propagate clones because
the female plants of hemp are the most
valuable it is desirable to propagate
all female plants
the plants that are produced by
micropropagation are clean and
disease-free
with new virus problems popping up with
hemp it is nice to have a clean source
of plants that grow vigorously
in addition this technique does not
require a large amount of space to
produce the plants
micro propagation requires less
maintenance than plants that are grown
in a greenhouse or field and year-round
production is possible
for the past two and a half years our
lab has been working on the
micropropagation of hemp we have been
studying the various factors that
influence the growth of this plant in
vitro
the medium on which the plants grow has
several reasons to succeed or fail so
each aspect needed to be evaluated we
examined the plant's nutrition amount of
sugar for optimum growth gelling agents
for the medium and the hormones that
allowed the plants to grow most
vigorously
in addition to the growing medium we
also examined other environmental
factors on him
we looked at the type of explant that
was used the temperature to grow the
plants and the medium ph levels i will
tell you what the key items for success
are
the ones that we found as we go through
this presentation
there are five stages of
micropropagations and i will review each
one of these in detail
first there is stage o stock plant
selection and preparation
stage one is the disinfection and
introduction of plant material into
tissue culture
stage two is the multiplication stage
stage three is rooting and stage four is
acclimation out of the culture vessel
vessel
okay i'm going to give you a spoiler
alert now we found at the end of this
research that stages three and four can
be combined for hemp and this shortens
the process decrease the cost and
increase sufficiency
stage 0 is for stock plant selection and
preparation
remembering that micropropagation allows
you to produce hundreds of thousands of
plants hundreds or thousands of plants
it is critical that you begin with the
correct cultivar it is best to begin
with plants that are healthy well
fertilized and disease-free
results of the plant's growth can
sometimes be affected by the time of
year in the plants are placed in vitra
the day length in which the plants are
growing the light intensity and several
other environmental factors can affect
the plant growth
during our research we examined the
effects of where the stock plants were
grown on the establishment in vitro
generally exploits that are taken from
plants that are grown in the field are
the most difficult to establish in vitro
expats that are taken from plants that
are grown in a greenhouse have a better
chance
and those that are taken from plants
that are grown in a growth chamber are
best
by removing plant material from plants
that are growing in a clean environment
you increase your chance of success at
stage one
stage one is the initiation and
establishment in vitro phase usually a
simple diluted bleach solution is used
to clean plant material we tested
various various levels of clorox bleach
for 10 minutes to see how well the
plants
were cleaned
you can see some of our results here and
there are two important takeaway
observations first ex-plants that were
removed from plants that were grown in
the growth chamber had a much higher
success rate than ex-plants that were
taken from plants that were grown in the
greenhouse
second the 20
40 and 60 bleach treatments all had
excellent cleaning abilities on the
expats that were taken from the growth
chamber
any of these levels work fine and
there's no damage to the plant material
based on these findings we recommend
twenty percent bleach for ten minutes to
clean hemp eggs plants for culture
other ways to improve your chances of
obtaining
a clean plant during stage one is to use
new shoots when possible they are
cleaner from fungi and bacteria than
older shoots
remember your ex plants from
i'm sorry remove your ex plants from
young plants they are better to respond
than older plants juvenile plants work
better than adult plants
one of the things about stage one is
that if it wasn't successful you will
visibly see contamination within three
to five days
here on the screen you see different
examples of fungal and bacterial attack
after unsuccessful stage one
the objective of stage two is the rapid
multiplication or propagation of
propagules during stage two the plant
material from stage 1 is repeatedly
subcultured until the desired number of
plants are obtained
a key part of the success of stage 2 is
the choice of cytokinins and auxins as
well as the concentrations of each that
are used this is a photo of five
different media that were used to grow
the same african violet plants media
that had cytokinins
and low levels of oxidants are on the
left
as you move to the right the levels of
cytokine and decrease and the levels of
auxins increase
you can see how the hormone level in the
medium can affect the growth of the
plant
more shoots are obtained with higher
levels of cytokinin and roots and or
callous can be produced when cytokinin
is absent and auxin levels are high
during stage two there are four
techniques that can be used to
micropropagate plants however there is
only one that can be
guaranteed to produce genetically
identical clones and that is number a on
this list use organized growing points
such as shoe tips and axillary buds
there are other ways to generate plants
during stage two such as somatic
embryogenesis adventitious shoot
production and seed propagation but none
of these techniques can guarantee clones
so i will not discuss them today
we found that hemp plants usually grow
in vitro by growing a single shoot with
no or very little axillary branching
this is an acceptable way
to micropropagate these plants
plants such as lilacs rhododendrons
mountain laurels and others
will grow in vitro by producing multiple
axillary branches hemp does not respond
this way
as i mentioned earlier during our stage
two research we focused on several
different media factors for optimal
growth we looked at sugar levels and by
the way for plant tissue culture you can
use plain old tablet table sugar
we compared levels from no sugar at all
all the way up to 60 grams per liter
usually 30 grams per liter is the
standard
we found that either 15 grams per liter
or 30 grams per liter were the best
levels to grow hemp we chose to use 15
grams per liter because it saves money
and you get the same results
we also compared four different
commercial media formulations mushig and
skoog indicated by ms linsmeyer and
skoog ls
driver in kuniyuki walnut media dkw as
well as lloyd and mcconnell's woody
plant medium the wpm
all the first three media performed
equally well the only medium that had
poor plant growth was the wpm meter
ms medium is the industry standard
around the world and we recommend that
medium because of convenience
we also compared gelling agents in the
micropropagation medium we compared
auger which is the most commonly used
gelling agent to jalen gum which is a
water-soluble polysaccharide
commercially it's called gel right and
then we also compared these to an auger
gelling combination there were no
significant differences between these
three gelling agents any can be used at
their recommended concentrations
we also compared the explant source for
stage two we compared shoot tips to
nodal sections there were no differences
between shoot tips and nodes either can
be used equally well
this is a good thing for commercial
propagators
another batch of experiments focused on
the ph levels of the medium for micro
propagation of him we tested ph levels
of four five five point eight which is
the industry standard six and seven we
found that the best ph levels were five
point eight six and seven we recommend
that the standard ph level five five
point eight be used for him
the optimum growing temperature
was also not known we grew hemp plants
in four different growing temperatures
we went from as
low as 22 degrees celsius
also 72 degrees fahrenheit all the way
up to 28 degrees celsius about 82
degrees fahrenheit the two warmest
temperatures 26 degrees and 28 degrees
had the best plant growth
these are recommended for hemp
micropropagation
a major set of experiments examined
different possible cytokinins and
different levels of each we compared
benzoyl amino purine ba to isopentanol
adenine 2ip as well as to this azron
which is indicated by tdz
this is not a cytokinin but it is a
chemical that has cytokine-like
activities
each were compared at 1 5 or 10
micromolar levels
the lower rates of 2ip or ba performed
the best
these growth regulators produced more
shoots than the control plants that had
no growth regulators
these two cytokines are what we
recommend for hemp at the lower
concentrations
tdz produced cultures with greater
number of nodes but the shoes were short
and callus was generated that azron is
not recommended because it produces
callus mutations are highly likely when
plants are produced indirectly through
callus
the last two stages of micropropagation
that we studied were stage three and
stage four stage three is used in
traditional micropropagation for root
initiation stage four is used to harden
off or acclimate plants
three for root initiation is to transfer
the hemp plants to a new medium with
either no cytokinin or to a medium that
includes an oxen
we compared the two most commonly used
auxins naa which is naphthalene acetic
acid and iba into 3-butyric acid
we compared them at four different
levels we had a control with no oxen
0.25 micromole
0.5 micromole and 2.5 micromole of each
we are recommending 2.5 micromole iba
for rooting hemp but as you can see here
roots are also possible with na
there was a lot of callus produced when
naa was the auxin and because we do not
want to encourage callus we think that
iba is the way to go
stage four is the acclimation or
hardening off of micropropagated plants
tissue culture plants are grown in 100
relative humidity so the plants do not
form cuticle wax on their leaves they
cannot be removed from tissue culture
and placed outside in the greenhouse or
field
they must be hardened off
this humidity surrounding the plant
needs to be gradually decreased because
the process to generate a waxy cuticle
on a leaf will only take 24 hours under
good conditions you can simply crack
open the culture vessel overnight
most often however plants are removed
from culture and transplanted into
greenhouse media they are then placed in
a high humidity environment
and then has the humidity lowered
gradually
another thing to do to micropropagated
plants when they removed from tissue
culture is to gradually increase light
intensity in photoperiod
plants and tissue culture do not
photosynthesize well because they have a
sugar source in the medium
by increasing the light levels and also
giving them long days the plants will
begin to photosynthesize and grow better
some stage four experiments compared
acclimating and rooting hemp plants
under intermittent mist or under a
plastic dome we also applied rooting
hormone to some of the plants and no
reading rooting hormone to the other
half to determine if rooting was
improved by the application of oxen
the plants on the right side of the
slide were rooted and acclimated under
a plastic dome and the plants on the
left side were placed under greenhouse
intermittent mist
plants that were grown under plastic
domes rooted faster and the plants were
healthier than plants that were placed
under the mist
the application of rooting hormone did
not have any advantage to the rooting
process we found that rooting and
hardening off of micropropagated plants
can easily be done together at stage
four for hemp plants there is no need to
go through a stage three
time and money can be saved by combining
these two stages
okay that's everything you need to know
about micropropagation of hemp in just
20 minutes i appreciate your attention i
hope this was helpful
i want to thank the young people in this
photo there the members of both our
ithaca lab and our long island lab they
do the real work for this research
thanks again and i can answer some
questions now if there are any
okay i'm going to have one maybe was
everybody else
so you're talking about callusing why is
that bad what is it
okay callus is just a group of
unorganized cells parenchyma's house
basically
and um
when
a plant is regenerated from a callous
cell uh there is a much greater chance
that there's a mutation that occurs um
and you and we want for this situation
we want clones so if we want clones we
need to start off with a organized
growing point which are basically the
shoot tip or those shoots and the
axillary buds
okay cool thing which is why you don't
want it early on because then you're
going to take that first plant and make
other little copies from that one and so
you don't want callous form on that
first
that's right so that okay yeah we get it
well thanks a lot mary uh thanks for the
invitation good afternoon everybody i'd
like to actually jump in on your comment
there mary uh
that even though i've been looking
fairly intensively at some of these
particularly foliar diseases on hemp
over the last several years uh it's
still awful nice to have a microscope
back at the lab and uh
the ability to grow these things out
because uh there's just enough
difference between cultivars uh
the genetics of hemp and the environment
location that you can still get pretty
easily fooled so i don't want to start
out making you all think that you can
just take a look and know what it is by
comparing it to uh some picture book but
let me share some of the things we've
been finding
and uh for starters i i want to
acknowledge when i started into this
work there there is not a heck of a lot
out there or wasn't at the time and the
literature is building nicely now but i
want to uh say hats off to uh uh jm
mcpartlin who is actually a physician
uh who was interested in some of the uh
the medical psychoactive uh
the of the hemp plant and he did put out
a beautiful uh textbook at the time on
hemp diseases and pests and that's been
a great starting point for learning
about a lot of these things
so let's start with some of the ones
that are kind of universal that uh
you're if you grow hemp for uh much time
at all you're probably going to run into
white mold
and this is caused by the fungus
sclerotinia sclerosiorum it's the fungus
with a very wide host range
and is problematic in new york on a
number of our vegetable crops
one of our biggest problems on soybean
production
so this is soil borne the overwintering
stage of the fungus is these uh hardened
uh bodies called sclerosia that reside
on the soil surface or within the soil
and uh white mold results for that from
that especially if
we get the little mushroom uh fruiting
body formed uh in the field about the
time that uh that hemp is starting to
flower
we can get infection and
i think one thing i want to call your
attention to here is
the concern about your crop rotations
what other crops you're going to grow in
rotation with him
and you want to be particularly cautious
if you're in a
uh in your rotation with a number of
particularly legume crops
uh
they can be vegetables they can be
things like soybean sunflower is a very
susceptible crop but anyhow be cautious
of what's in the crop uh preceding
hemp and uh what diseases have built up
there
grey mold is probably the most universal
thing that i can almost guarantee
anybody growing
uh hemp whether it be in the field or in
a in a controlled climate situation
you're going to run into this gray mold
but us at the end of the season
and uh it can cause problems because it
grows all over the all over the buds the
flower parts and and in fact other parts
of the plant and can cause a seed
quality
a bud quality issue uh
in in the eventual use of this uh of
this crop
again it has a very wide host range
you're probably not going to
avoid this by rotation
but uh something to be aware of
generally
pottery mildew i won't say much about it
because chris martin her group have
worked on this but it's something you're
really like to
you're likely to see
at least low levels of in the field and
if you're in a controlled climate uh
humid situation like a greenhouse you're
very likely to run into more of this so
i won't steal uh
chris's groups thunder and they will be
talking about this
um i think all of you know that the
early part of the life cycle of a hemp
plant
when you plant seed
or seedlings for that matter the the
crop is is not really competitive at its
early stages
and amongst the various things that
plague it are the omic
problem uh pythium species causing
pythium wilts
and compared to a number of other
vegetable ornamental crops hemp is
particularly susceptible
and we see this in both field and
greenhouse operations
and we've worked for a couple years now
with alan taylor
at the
cornell agritech
and uh
alan's worked out a nice uh if we can't
always get out look at this in the field
setting
we've got some nice assays there where
you take infested field soil and you
bring it back into the lab and dilute
that out with sand and use these rag
doll systems where you germinate the
seeds
and what we particularly see is in
post-emergent seedling death
and this is 4 7 10 days
after planting these seeds in these
systems
and
we've been looking at this with alan
to hopefully identify some seed
treatments both chemical and biological
that can help get around this
unfortunately at this particular point
none of the uh the approved available
biological treatments are really doing a
very significant job
some of the chemical fungicide
treatments are
doing well
but there's
next to nothing labeled for hemp so
that's a that's a continuing challenge
and when we've looked at uh pathogens
coming from soil in this assay uh that
alan's developed it's not only pythium
but they're another a number of other
soil-borne fungal genera species such as
fusarium and rhizoctomy tonia in
particular can also
give rise to the damping off symptoms
so the fusarium fungus is uh is very uh
cosmopolitan we we find it in in many
soils and uh
certainly we have seen instances where
fusarium uh particularly fusarium
oxysporum types
can
infect
usually through the roots or crown of
the plant and depending on the timing
the growth stage of the plant we can see
you know premature death of plants we
can see crown and foot rots or or
complete vascular will that kills off
the planet
i'll talk a little bit also about
certain fusarium fungi can infect uh
through the flower parts and cause a
flower of bud blight
and we're concerned about that not only
because of the damage it does directly
but the fusarium fungi produce a number
of mycotoxins that can be harmful to
humans and animals
so that's an issue uh downstream in the
products
so we have found
several species of fusarium associated
with these flower blights but uh
predominant amongst them we find uh
fusarium graminiarum which i have spent
the better part of my career working on
in grain crops it's the cause of uh our
principal cause of ear rot and corn and
fusarium head blight in
things like wheat and barley
and there are a number of mycotoxins but
principally we find the toxin
called in the vernacular vomit toxin
because of the effect that it has on
animals but it's uh known as deoxynol or
shortened to d-o-n
and in grain crops uh
we are concerned at levels above five
part per million
and for human food you don't want more
than one part per million that's
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
in a in a total feed for a human or an
animal
so
we have indeed found uh levels uh in
harvested uh
hemp grain
uh well exceeding five parts per million
uh we did some brief experiments uh
preliminary experiments where we pressed
with a commercial oil plant we had some
of that grain pressed to make oil
and
most of that
resided in the press cake that's left
behind and relatively little dawn went
into the oil so that's one
piece of good news increasingly there's
interest in
what the don toxin will uh how important
that will be as a contaminant in in the
cbd product chain
so i don't mean anybody to uh to read
this table
on the left hand side there's a list of
very commonly occurring
uh fusarium species that we see here in
new york particularly on grain crops
and each column across that are unique
types of mycotoxins that are produced
so what i'm saying is we're keyed in at
this point on on one of those toxins the
oxygen of aldol but we find some of
these other fusarium species so more
work really needs to be done to see if
any of these other toxins
are potential issues
in in the uh processing of products for
uh coming from him
so uh in the first couple of years that
i worked with hemp in new york state we
did survey work
i found only one or two fields with the
septoria leaf spot also known as yellow
leaf spot
now i would say that this is our most
prevalent prevalent foliar disease in
new york state
these spores are born in the residue of
old uh
of old crops of hemp
i cannot rule out that they might not be
surviving on other crops we just don't
know enough but this septoria cannabis
you'll start to see these lesions on the
lower part of the plant canopy
uh as the season progresses with
splashing rain the spores are splashed
increasingly upward in the canopy
the spots expand
they have pronounced yellowish margins
around the the brownish dead areas
and we have seen these now
almost becoming more prominent each year
in the last three years and and we saw
quite a lot of this
in uh in 2022 as well
so i have a little uh video here of
disease prior kind of what it looks like
in a canopy that these were uh
a little movie put together by jen starr
and you can get down in the canopy and
see a little bit what the development of
this septorial leaf spot looks like and
again
for a lot of these things you look first
on the lower leaves
and as the the crop progresses you'll
see these things
under the right environment move up in
the canopy
so the first couple years that we
started working on on hemp in new york
the the most prevalent thing i saw was
by polaris leaf spot
and the folks in kentucky were the first
to characterize this they refer it to as
hemp leaf spot i kind of don't prefer
that because all of these are hemp leaf
spots so i i like the name that with the
organism that kind of distinguishes this
but they these start as kind of pinpoint
white spots on the leaves
uh scattered specks
and as they grow and develop uh
you can see in some of those pictures
there they have kind of a darker edge to
them with kind of a a light tan or
whitish center
now as those grow and coalesce
that pattern may go away and they can
become looking a lot more like the
saptoria for instance so that's why
these things are uh are kind of
complicated and you almost need to uh to
look at your your field scout them
progressively through the season
um this is an interesting one that we
need to learn a lot more about
it's a documented pathogen of number of
monocots of grasses and also of some
dicots and and weeds things like velvet
leaf
we don't precisely know the epidemiology
in a place like new york with this yet
but this is probably the most frequently
uh reported foliar disease
across everywhere that uh that hemp is
grown in north america
so i've got a little uh close-up of this
as well in the canopy
and you can see how it uh it kind of has
that kind of
bleached look before it starts turning
uh
darker
sets it apart at least at least from the
early stages of the septoria
so a couple of years ago we first uh we
first discovered in some of the cornell
plots in ithaca
uh the presence of an o my seat pathogen
downy mildew
and this is uh this is an obligate
parasite so it uh it it survives in in
green living tissue
um what you see here you really need to
look at both leaf surfaces here
on the upper leaf surface you see this
kind of kind of non-distinct the
distinct light green
lesion but you turn that over and you
see these uh
darker colorations
and you see the actually uh the
sporulation
of the causal oh my seat
under human great conditions like when
the uh
uh
when you still have due out in the
morning is a good time to look for this
and we have seen this now for a couple
of seasons
under fairly uh
in a couple of different locations but
at this point at least not widespread
across the state
and these are the uh characteristics uh
uh
spores the uh sporangia and the
sporangia force here
uh that that you may see under a
powerful hand lens or under a microscope
and a little little video of this as
these lesions progress
uh even on the upper side they become
more angular and much darker in color
as you can see they kind of fill in
those uh leaf panels in kind of a very
uh sorry angular shape
very distinctive
and uh
we don't know enough about this yet but
i think uh working with larry's program
and and uh
chris's program in the future they'll be
looking at uh at different varieties
different cultivars
and
just a quick look at this we looked at
three different ratings on the hemp
essential oil cultivars and you can see
there is a there's not
a complete resistance but there are
definitely
some cultivars
by comparison that show
less or slower development of downy
mildew
so one really striking finding a couple
of years ago in 2019
in in the variety the cultivar plots
located in ithaca new york
we found a foliar rust which is
really striking because this had not
been described in any way in north
america
and we found these uh the yellow
orangish uh pustules the orange rust
stage of this uh rust fungus uh and
almost exclusively on the lower leaf
surface so you could easily miss this
going through a field
you might see some light yellow spots on
the upper surface you really need to
look on the lower leaf surface
we have seen this now recurrence in all
three of the last growing seasons and in
a few different locations but still not
widely dispersed across the state
and this has also had been observed in
sort of the mid-south region in virginia
and tennessee
this is what the uh uradinia spores
those orange rust spores look like
under a microscope
and uh again these were born on uh the
lower leaf surface
so uh the the book i showed you uh
initially
referenced this as an issue
in uh in a few places in northern europe
and it was uh originally described
by
uh a person called krieger a mycologist
and it was identified as urido which is
kind of a
a bucket of uh uh taxonomically of of
related uh genera of uh rust fungi it's
it's not a finely
defined uh genus but he decided he
described this as urito trigariana
and
we were extremely lucky to find a part
of a type specimen
in cornell's herbarium and this dates to
more than a hundred years ago found in
germany
and you know there's been no recent
citation in the literature
of rust as an issue
frankly anywhere in the world even in
northern europe so
uh we tried to get dna from the limited
sample that we had here to try to
compare uh sequence with the modern one
but uh
we weren't able to get dna out of this
ancient
uh sample but we were able to compare
the description of the spores
matched up very well with our modern
sample and and we have now deposited
sequence uh for the isolate from new
york
over time we have seen a lot of just a
few other things that we see off and on
cercospora we see stem fillium leaf
spots but none of these have really
become
that common across the state we may see
them with one cultivar one location in
one year
and a number of other
pathogens such as colitotricum species
etc so
this is kind of a continuing evolving
scene
one thing that fascinates me very much
is what's the life cycle of these things
in terms of the host range so for
instance we were interested we saw in
the same field that we saw sarcospora on
the hemp we saw a lot of cercospora on
lamb's quarters weeds in the field they
may or may not be the same but i think a
lot of these kind of puzzles need to be
solved
this is one that we have seen a couple
years ago
but in the very wet growing season of
2021
we saw a number of fields where this was
far and away the most extensive blight
and this is a fungus called
cristulariella or or drosinia
and uh
we found this under the very wet
conditions uh very prevalent across many
varieties uh even across uh cbd
varieties and uh and forage type uh
varieties
and here's an interesting thing this
fungus has a very wide host range and we
noticed in the one location in the
southern tier in new york
we saw a box elder tree that was just
loaded with these zone eight leaf spots
we collected the fungus from the box
elder as well as from the hemp
we sequenced dna and we got a 100
percent identical sequence
to the rocinia
muricula
match with both our hemp and our uh
tree isolate so that's fascinating and
again comes back to the question what is
the host range of some of these things
that we're finding
um i won't talk about this but
occasionally we see a bacterial leaf
spot
this is one discovered in the smart lab
this is a a red pigmented bacterium
seratio marcescens that can also be
found uh as a blight
so uh very briefly i think many of you
know this already
if you go to the
nizepad
site of new york department of
environmental conservation
look at registered pesticides for new
york
if you if you initiate a search there
and go into the next level where you do
an advanced search
and then down on the bottom left there
you click industrial hemp
it will show about 107 different
products
these are by and large least toxic
chemicals
biological treatments
things that are uh kind of generally
available
for organic
control many of them are on the omri
list
but this is this is a source of seeing
what things might be available
um we don't ha i know that chris is
going to talk about this uh in a few
minutes here
we have done very limited look at some
of these necrotrophic
leaf spot pathogens
and have not seen anything really
overwhelming control with any of these
materials but
some people have looked at
some of the biological control
materials and and reported at least
anecdotally some positive results
so what do you do in the midst of all
this first of all the vast majority of
these diseases
are not directly directly
hurting yield and quality
so really key in on those that develop
early and actually are attacking either
the the
the flower part of the plant or
attacking the foliage early enough to
reduce yield
prevention's our best tool still
uh some of these things are seed borne
potentially or soil borne so
paying attention to uh you know getting
clean seed
having good soil health practices uh
spacing out
uh your plantings to reduce
uh humidity and get air flow in the
canopy
uh a really good idea to remove any
debris
of hemp of a previous
hemp crop off of your your field and
either burn it or completely compost it
weed control is important
i mentioned a little bit of the part we
know there's a lot we don't know in
terms of crop rotations where white mold
is an issue
in some of the legume crops or other
crop vegetable crops
you want to be cautious there
and in terms of mycotoxins the fusarium
mycotoxins on the on the flower parts
uh probably corn and small grains
rotations
are not a really great idea which is
tough because for other reasons they'd
be excellent rotational crops so there's
uh there's a lot we need to know yet
and in addition we talked about things
that could be sprayed i think a lot of
emphasis in the future
will be on uh looking at cultivars that
are more resistant than others
so in terms of diagnostics i'm kind of a
short-termer in this business i will not
be uh entertaining uh
diagnostic samples in my lab this uh
coming growing season um
chris smart may or may not be uh looking
for certain type of samples but i want
to uh make you aware that uh
the plant disease diagnostic clinic
based in ithaca is
really geared up
to look at
at hemp samples this year
sandra jensen has worked with us in the
last two growing seasons to really
become attuned to diagnosing hemp
diseases uh but this is through the
clinic a fee based service
so just some uh kind of uh
pointers on uh sending plants in uh
particularly foliage samples is uh the
cardinal rule don't add any water to the
sample
just flatten out your leaves and and put
them in dry paper towels you can put
them then in a ziploc bag but don't
whatever you do don't put moisture into
that ziploc and these can maybe the
sooner they get to the lab the better
usually you want to avoid shipping them
over the over the weekend
and it's always a good idea to call the
lab that you say you have something
coming
so with that uh mary that's my comments
and if we have time
for a couple of questions i'd uh
love to uh answer them
okay we got one in chat what are the
best cultivars to use in new york
well we're going to have a lot of chat
well not a lot of chat but there's other
cultivars coming up but may i think
maybe since it's gary are there any
cultivars that have you've seen that are
particularly disease resistant
not really i i mean for most of these
things we've been talking about if you
look at septoria look at donnie mildew
you look at several things it
you're looking at partial resistance
would be my best guess you're looking at
shades of gray i'm not we haven't
purposefully have done a lot of that
work other than we've tried to look at
uh larry's plots in ithaca and geneva
and whatnot just look for whatever
mother nature provided
uh we have not done any of uh what i
would do my cereal crops for instance is
actually inoculate plots and you know
take no survive you know
have no uh take no prisoners and uh so
we can make some very general
conclusions at this point but maybe one
of the later speakers
um there's no miracle cultivar at this
point
uh
and we just don't know enough uh to to
make that kind of a broad uh
representation
i would say as somewhat of a
generalization
the cbd type varieties
seem to be uh quantitatively more
susceptible as a class
than than the fiber or the grain types
and again that's a little subjective
because that's going out looking at the
at the variety trials and uh you know
that's not a direct comparison where
it's been inoculated the the only thing
i'll throw into that is because the cbd
types are typically grown more like
tomatoes very far away from one another
instead of like the grain types were in
there it's like a jungle yep i've never
seen scleritinia on cbd types
but in the grain and fiber types it's
not hard to find at all that's just me
what i've seen so that to me is about
the the environment you provide just
based on density
well that's a good point and and air
movement in these canopies is critical
uh if you want to tamp down the some of
these fungal diseases they love moisture
and humidity i have seen
scleretinia in a white mold in cbd types
and even in uh in hoop houses where the
soil that was brought in from somewhere
to put in the hoop house had
had uh you know the sclerotinia in it so
it's it's not even just crop rotation in
the field but think about where your
soil is coming from what other crops
it's been exposed to
um i do have a couple of just general
comments or quest two one comment your
questions pythium
this
i know i i can hear chris laughing when
i say it this crap is
uh shamelessly susceptible to pithium so
i'm gonna bring back you know mark's
greenhouse and we've got some other
stuff going on that like sanitation
sanitation sanitation sanitation right
all the time everywhere no matter what
just throwing that out there um other
questions i have so the on the downy
mildew
yeah clearly that's a different genus
and species which people on the call
need to know that there's a lot of
different genius and species that we
call downy mildew across a variety of
you know crops that we grow
so that's one they're not all the same
downy but two
is this one is
is it as
quickly it doesn't spread as quickly
does it you know take over a plant as
quickly i mean downing on things like
basil and some other crops i mean in a
matter of days it
absorbs the whole thing
and is really hard to control even if
you have a fairly decent chemical for it
just forget it if you don't get it the
first like 24 hours it's done
there's no beating it back
well the two parts to your question the
the first one is that we did see
under favorable environment
fairly rapid progress i i it's not like
in a greenhouse setting uh but yeah it
was fairly rapid progress on the other
hand i don't have a good feel for spread
at this point because we've seen him in
in very limited
geographies
so
you know there's a lot to learn there
but it hasn't been a distributed problem
so far just in a a few small
locations but you know how that goes
once something spreads then uh you know
all right yeah and i will continue to
discover new things i like your point
mary about common names and even
genus names so for instance
um
when i talked about subterra of septoria
flight well there's satori blight on
tomatoes on wheat i know they those are
all different pathogens okay so just
because something has a latin name in
the in the uh in the title that that
also does not mean it's uh
it's uh not different use of that common
name right right and different crops so
that's that's a great point
and and yet
some of these things i just because of
the way they're appearing and the
patterning i think probably have another
host out there whether it's a weed or a
grown
uh cultivated crop
so it's going to really take a while to
ferret out some of that business
what
and my other question was you mentioned
the mycotoxins um and i assume you're
we're talking about for seed production
for either human or animal consumption
that's what we're worried about yeah so
are there standards for canadian hemp
seeds in terms of how much of what
mycotox and so that
because they certainly have a pretty big
market on that well for all human food
products um
it's basically one part per million
that's milligrams per kilogram
and that that's for broad variety of
commodity crops so i would think this
wouldn't be any different
um and there at least at one point in
canada if it's something that goes into
baby food it's even more it's like a
half a part per million
no not i don't know with that yeah no i
was just baby but
yeah
they're making most of the seed right
now or anything we had a we had a really
critical situation with field corn in
new york state this past growing season
with with d.o.n
and harvested corn i mean it's it's a
really bad situation and uh in some uh
mills that are taking it for like
ethanol the average is coming in with
three parts per million
in corn and we have
uh
i won't name names but we had one place
that that had 50 parts per million
and shelled corn
this past growing season so
we definitely don't want to run into
anything like that with him okay because
that's that's the sort of thing that
just could kill a crop a new crop
so
so my emails gcb3
at cornell.edu i welcome
questions if they don't occur to you
right now
all right so i'm patrick mcmullen one of
the graduate students in chris smart's
lab
and today we're all going to be
discussing results from our 2021 disease
field trials
um so the particular disease that i work
primarily on
is fusarium vascular wilt of hemp
um and as you can see from this image
here
uh fusarium vascular will causes a
pretty severe
collapse of the plant if it reaches
these later stages
and we've seen this across new york
state in a number of different scenarios
so
first i'd like to discuss some of the
disease signs and symptoms that we most
commonly witness witnessed
some of our current management
strategies available
and then
some results from our fungicide and
growth promoting inoculate
inoculation
trials
and a new project that we're beginning
with copper zinc
copper fungicide treatments
so
first fusarium vascular will can be
caused by a number of different fusarium
species
primarily these three listed here
fusarium oxyspring selenite or
proliferatum and we've seen all three of
these in new york state so far
um with fusarium oxyspram being the most
common by far
here are some pictures that i've taken
in earlier field seasons
where
if we start over here on the right
there's this
young transplant that the root system
never fully developed outside of its
initial plug and the roots were bound
and unable to grow enough to support the
plant
and then over here on the left is an
image of an older more mature plant
that suffered a similar
a similar scenario
where these
roots were not large enough there was
not enough root biomass to support the
upper parts of the plant and the plant
will then collapse
and some of these
characteristics symptoms of fusarium
wilt are some reddening of the roots it
might be a little hard to see in this
image
but reduced root biomath mass and
reddening of the roots are common
so a little bit more about the pathogen
um it primarily infects the root system
of the plant through these little tiny
microconidia that can infiltrate through
the root hairs and these will
germinate and produce
hyphae and mycelium within the xylem the
water transporting vessels of the plant
where a mass of hyphae will accumulate
and block water flow to the upper parts
of the plant
and that's what leads to the wilting and
plant collapse
so the disease cycle that we've seen um
in the field
it primarily occurs where we have these
asexual spores like we saw in the last
slide
that can survive in the soil for a long
time
and then they'll germinate enter the
root system
and as it colonizes the xylem like we
said it will block water flow
and at this point this is when you start
to see the red or browning of the root
tissue and the xylem and then you'll
start to see yellowing on the upper
parts of the plant and eventually
wilting chlorosis and complete collapse
and when the plant collapses that's when
these new spores will be released into
the soil
these hardy
clamitos force they're called can
survive in the soil for quite a long
time so it's a difficult pathogen to
eradicate once it's there
some of our management strategies right
now
are quite limited
we don't know of any genetic resistance
which we often rely on genetic
resistance as our first line of defense
but some good sanitation practices can
help reduce
disease in the field
so it's important to remove infected
planting material
gary mentioned this a bit in his
presentations that you have to be
careful
where you're getting your soil from make
sure you're not moving soil between
fields especially in
diseased fields
ensure adequate drainage in the field
since the this fungus likes moist
environment avoid planting in those low
wet areas of your field
crop rotation may help but this pathogen
does have quite a wide host range
um and as we've seen with most diseases
in hemp approved fungicides are fairly
limited and efficacy is often unknown so
to answer this last question we set up a
field experiment
two summers ago or last summer
that studied
some commercially available products and
their efficacy in controlling fusarium
wealth of them
so we tested a copper based product from
vm agrotech
and then some different biological
strain products so we had a pseudomonas
inoculant bacillus and a trichoderma
product
and then we inoculated the field with
fusarium
and unfortunately we just had low
disease pressure over that season our
inoculation method wasn't quite um
substantial enough that we could
adequately evaluate these products so
these are some areas of research that
we're still interested in and trying to
evaluate what products can effectively
control fusarium will
um this pathogen can also cause damping
off like we've seen with pythium and
some other soil borne pathogens on the
left here is a flat that was not
inoculated with fusarium and then on the
right here is one that was and you could
just see the significant reduction in
germination
so i'm currently working on a product to
see how we can
prevent some of this damping off and
what available management strategies we
have
so i'm currently using a copper based
fungicide a newly um developing product
from vm agrotech
and here i just plated the fungus
fusaramox system
on our petri plates and these have
increase in concentrations of the copper
fungicide
from none which is our control
all the way up to 200 parts per million
and you can see as we move across the
gradient there's less fungal growth and
then once we get up to
75 percent or
100 of these concentrations the 200
parts per million or 150 there's very
little growth if any of usarium
so now we're working with alan taylor's
lab to determine a strategy to apply
this product as a seed a seed coat
and have to see if this will increase
germination rates
so essentially what i've seen so far is
that i've been studying fusaramox's
system is a soil-borne pathogen can
survive in the soil for a long time and
it's quite difficult to manage and
eradicate
management strategies at this moment
rely primarily on cultural practices
since we don't have good fungicides
available and we don't really know much
about their advocacy
so more research is needed on the
efficacy of these fungicides
and
the
research for the copper fungicide seed
treatment is ongoing
and now i'll hand it over to ally to
talk about padre mildew
great thanks patrick um so i
my name's ali and i'm also a phd student
in chris's lab and i am working on
powdery mildew on hemp um so
um
if you've ever grown just about anything
you're probably somewhat familiar with
some kind of powdery mildew but um in
case you're not um this powdery mildew
is caused by golovinomyces ambrosia
and
it's characterized by
asexual spores on the surface of the
leaf and
um
it's also
a pathogen that needs living tissue to
grow so um we can't culture it we need
to grow it on whole plants when we work
with it in the lab
and so these um
the asexual spores on surface of the
leaf you can see here on this first
picture on the left
and then if you were to
um zoom in on that leaf you would see
those canadia in long
chains
um in like you can see in this middle
photo here
and then on the right um there's a photo
of what those individual spores look
like and those spores
are carried in the wind and can cause
new infections
on new plant on um
healthy tissue um
so next slide please patrick okay um so
for this project i was looking at ways
to control powdery mildew particularly
looking at fungicide use
so
currently there's not too many options
to control diseases with
fungicides on hemp
what is labeled for hemp in new york
state are mostly omri listed and most of
those are biologicals um and then more
importantly um what is listed there's
limited publications on
the efficacy of those fungicides against
hemp pathogens
specifically
so thank you patrick um
so the goal of this project is um
twofold so first to compare some of
those currently labeled products that
are available to use on hemp
on
for use to control
hemp powdery mildew
and then the second part of this project
was to look at whether both powdery
mildew infection
or fungicide or the fungicide treatments
we were testing would affect cannabinoid
production in hemp
as well uh since we
we know that a lot of uh folks are
growing hemp for uh cannabinoid
production we thought this would be
um a good question to look at
next please patrick so in
2020 we
did our first fungicide trial um with
some of these products
and these are the products that we used
in that
um in that trial so we had lifeguard and
double nickel which are two different
uh bacillus treatments um and then we
had a treatment where we were
alternating the uh lifeguard in the
double nickel
um every other week and then we had
still matrix which is the potassium
silicate
um and then lastly we had
azoxy strobin which is a conventional
fungicide
and uh the azoxy strobin we expected to
um essentially work against the powdery
mildew since we know his oxystrobin
works for other powdery mildews
but as oxy strobin is not currently
labeled for use on hemp so it's not
actually
something that a hemp grower could use
but we were using it as more of a
positive control for um this experiment
and then we also had an untreated
control plot as well
and then we applied all of these weekly
throughout the season starting before
our first inoculation
next slide please um
so um in 2020 uh
this was how we set up our experiment so
we had um
we used the cultivar tj cbd
and we grew up our inoculum on full
plants in a growth chamber
and then to make up an inoculum i rinsed
um
washed infected leaves with a water in
tween solution and then sprayed that
solution on plants using a backpack
sprayer
and then i did this three different
times
and then
once we got disease in the field i rated
those plants five times
once a week
and i rated them for percentage of
disease coverage and then
calculated the area under the disease
progress curve
and then i also collected um
inflorescence or flowers at the end of
the season for cannabinoid analysis
to address that second question
next please um okay so this is our uh
our results for
uh that first trial in 2020 so on our
x-axis here you can see are the
different fungicide treatments so we
have our untreated control
lifeguard which is the first bacillus
treatment cell matrix was which was that
potassium silicate
lifeguard alternating with double nickel
double nickel being the second bacillus
treatment
double nickel by itself
um and are as oxystrobin
on the y-axis was the area under the
disease progress curve
and those letters on top of the bars
indicate two keys groups
um so the same if the bars have the same
letters they're statistically the same
to
the other the same letters
to each other
so
you can see in this graph the large bars
indicate more disease
so our untreated control had the most
disease um and then our zoxie strobin
had the least amount and did a really
good job at controlling the powdery um
but like i said before the exoxy
strobin's not actually labeled for use
on him but it did work the way we
expected
um but also the cell matrix the
lifeguard alternating with double nickel
and then the double nickel
all
uh reduced
disease significantly compared to
untreated control
so that was great so we decided to um
yeah next slide
to uh repeat this experiment in 2021
with just a few minor changes so
this
past year we used a different cultivar
white cvg which we
had more information to know that white
cbg was a more susceptible host to
powdery mildew
um and then my my inoculum was made in
the same way as the year before
and uh but this time i just inoculated
one time i rated the same way and
collected flowers um in the same way as
20 20. next slide please
so here are our results from 2021 again
our treatments on the x-axis audpc on
the y
and two keys letters and again our
untreated control had the most
disease
and our exoxy strobin again worked quite
well
and then once again we saw the lifeguard
alternating with double nickel the cell
matrix and the double nickel
also
significantly reduced disease severity
um
compared to the untreated control
so that second part of this project was
looking at cannabinoid production so
um there's lots of different
cannabinoids that are produced by hemp
um and we just looked at a few to get an
idea and
we looked at a lot but i'm going to just
talk about a few
we looked at so today i'm going to talk
about total potential thc
cbd
cbg and cbc
um so in this experiment we i collected
flowers from each of the treatment plots
and
looked at the levels of all those so um
next slide please patrick so when we
looked at thc
we saw that there was no um
effect on the total potential thc thc so
there's two graphs here both from 2020
and 2021. um the x-axis shows all of the
different um
the treatments for each year
and then the y-axis is showing the total
potential
uh thc for each of those treatments and
we didn't see any difference between any
of the treatments in either
year next slide please
so next we also looked at um total
potential cbd and again um
very
similar type of graph our treatments are
on the x-axis and the total potential
cbd on the y
and again there was no differences
between the different treatments in
either 2021 or 2021.
and once again we saw the same thing
with
the total potential
cbg next please
and
again the same for the total potential
cbc
one more um so we also
looked at whether pottery mildew
infection would affect cannabinoid
levels so i for this i had a separate
plot
that was both uninoculated and untreated
with any powdery mildew and i collected
flowers from
um
from plants that were um from that
untreated
control plot um so that's our powdery
mildew those were inoculated and then
from that separate plot that were
uninoculated and for um total potential
thc cbd cbg and cbc
i didn't see any
significant differences
in those
cannabinoids between
plants that were infected with powdery
mildew and plants that were uninoculated
um and
yeah so
uh to wrap up um some of the products
that are available for growers to use in
new york um were effective at reducing
powdery mildew disease pressure so yay
good news
and those fungicide treatments and
powdery mildew both did not
affect cannabinoid production in him
and that's all
right thank you ali um
gary covered a couple of diseases i was
gonna highlight because we we saw them
quite a bit in the last two years
um i
i'll cover a few things my hat my lab is
continuing to work
in addition to fusarium and powdery
mildew on hemp downy mildew
um
and uh
we also in my lab work on cucurbit
downy mildew um and
one of the questions was how how rapidly
will it spread
and the the picture that you see here
is an inflorescence this was from 2020
in the plots that uh savannah shellnut
and the bergstrom lab were rating
and um it it actually
you know that it didn't kill the plant
so if this were cucurbit you know a
cucumber and cucurbit downy mildew the
plant would be dead fairly quickly you
know maybe two weeks
maybe depending on the weather um and
and the the plants did not die but they
are in no way healthy right if you look
at this flower it's not something you're
going to want to harvest and sell right
away so um
i i think
as gary said we just we have a lot to
learn
about
some of the diseases that are that are
moving into our hemp crops um
it this particular pathogen much like
the powdery mildew will spread via wind
we we don't yet know
how far you know for
for closely related organisms we have a
better idea as to how far the sporangia
might fly
in the wind and um
we don't yet know for downy mildew but
based on uh hop and cucurbit uh downy
mildews
we can
you know assume that it it could be a
mile
um
they are the spores actually if you go
to the next slide patrick the
the symptoms gary showed really nicely
and then in the next slide
um you can see
uh the the sporangia they're gray
um and so the
they have some protection from
ultraviolet uh as they're flying in the
air and and they they don't seem to
desiccate really quickly one of the
things that uh we have seen
is that
um so on the bottom of the leaf in the
in the upper left-hand corner um you see
the underside of the leaf with the with
the gray spores being formed and then in
the lower left hand you see uh the
spores or sporangia well in water those
sporangia will actually release swimming
zoo spores and there's a picture of a
zospore in that slide and it's those
zospores that will actually um
germinate and cause cause the infection
on the leaf
in some downy mildews uh the sporangia
the spore the larger spore can directly
germinate if there's not enough water uh
so uh
hop downy mildew can do that but in
cucurbit downy mildew um you only have
the production of zoospores the reason
that's important
is because there are different control
products that are effective for
different types of spores in the
pathogen
the other thing that unfortunately we
have found is the overwintering spore so
on the right hand side of the slide you
can see it says within leaf tissue
that thick brown circle
that's the called the o spore it's the
overwintering spore and those will
survive in the soil so if you plant hemp
the next season you are
going to have that inoculum already in
the soil as you start your season
and
these are some of the things that that
we're thinking about and trying to
figure out okay what what experiments do
we really want to look for if we think
hemp downy mildew is going to show up
more frequently
next slide
so
what are we working on uh we are
screening as much germplasm as we can
for resistance
uh
you know for some pathogens against this
type of omic pathogen you know in tomato
and potato there's actually quite a biz
quite a bit of resistance um that can be
found and it's not always used in
agriculture but but there are resistance
genes there
er for cucurbit downy mildew there's
really not as much in all the screening
that's been done there's really not a
lot of resistance available in the plant
host germplasm
um so we're going to be screening a
whole bunch of varieties and and seeing
where where we come out for hemp downy
mildew
we also hope to sequence the pathogen
genome to get an idea is it really more
closely related to the hemp or the hop
again that might give us better clues
into control strategies
and one of the reasons i really wanted
to highlight this is we are collecting
isolates to look at pathogen diversity
so do we all have the same thing uh when
we see it we we did get an isolate
from massachusetts last year
unfortunately it died one of the things
that's really hard working with this
pathogen is that you can't grow it uh in
culture like patrick showed cultures of
fusarium you can't grow this pathogen in
culture it has to be grown on living
tissue um so that makes it a big
challenge so uh
as gary said you know
we really do recommend that you send
samples to the diagnostic lab they're
they're really excellent and have had a
lot of experience now in
diagnosing hemp
diseases um but if you think you might
have downy mildew um we would love to
have isolates of the pathogen and i
think the same is true of the fusarium
root rots
i know this this is bad for for growers
but as researchers we are looking for
the most aggressive pathogens so that we
can include those in our tests so if you
do have um
aggressive you know if
plants that are dying from either root
rots or what might be downy mildew we
would love to have those samples um and
then patrick you can just go to the last
slide
the next yep uh i want to make sure that
we highlight the department of ag
markets in new york state they have
provided all of the funding
um for the work that we have done in the
lab
that we presented today and and they
have enabled new york uh to really get a
jump on some of the
hemp research compared to other states
and so we really want to thank the state
of new york and with that uh patrick you
can stop sharing and we're happy to
answer any questions
or move on oh we we caught up some time
there mary
like two minutes
yes you did thank you yeah i actually
have a question so patrick
mentioned using double nickel
as a fusarium control is that really
like going to work soil apply
or is it a drench or a spray or you know
a dip for the transpl how is it yeah we
did a
um a drench on the soil
and in talking to service they they
didn't think it would work but it was
one of those well if you're doing the
trial you know
okay let's give it up what does that
work on does it work on other things can
we like okay because i had only ever
heard of it as a full airplane all right
so it's like real research
um that was the only question i had
and i will like you know
i do want to mention again that
the roots on these plant on hemp are
just so sad
compared to other crops i mean they're
just you know patrick showed those
pictures of you know fusarium and that
the roots didn't really spread out that
really if you don't
dig the hole correctly for the
transplant
even without disease you can have a
problem because they're just not
as aggressive as you would expect that
amount of top growth
like a little christmas tree
you would expect the bottom to have more
umph and it just doesn't
the other thing i'll highlight mary is
that ali has done a really nice host
range study with powdery mildew and um
those results uh from this past summer
will be posted up on that hemp website
okay that jan has posted before good
so uh
just to get started i just want to go
into a little background on what a full
season plant and what an autoflower
plant is so on the left side here you
have a full season plant which is deep
length sensitive and on the right you
have an autoflower plant which is also
known as a day length insensitive plant
and so our full season cultivars are
triggered to flower when the critical
night
length reaches a certain threshold
so that means that the plant receives a
signal to flower as the nights increase
in length and our autoflowers don't
receive that signal so therefore
independently of daily
and uh just some general notes full
season plants usually are larger
and have a longer time to maturity at
around three to four months and they're
usually planted at a lower density than
autoflowers which are relatively smaller
in stature
and have a shorter time to maturity at
two to three months and they're usually
planted at a much higher density and so
this short time maturity can enable
double cropping
with another round of autumn flowers or
you can come in and follow up with
something that's going to grow late into
the season like a brassica
so low density versus high density so
when i talk about low density plantings
i'm referring to a traditional
horticultural style planting usually
spacing's around four foot by six foot
which results in roughly two thousand
plants per acre
um and generally plants are transplanted
into these plantings with a water wheel
transplanter by hand
and they can be planted into bare ground
or into horticultural plastic to control
weeds
and generally these plantings are
irrigated with drip irrigation on the
right side over here we have a high
density direct seeded planting savannah
this is janice your slides aren't
advancing you're on the full season
versus autoflower slide still thank you
so much janice i appreciate it
i'm not just so you can see this picture
of flowers really quickly because i
don't think you guys saw it this on the
and uh full season plants left side we
have our full season right side we have
odd flowers
all right so uh just once again low
density versus high density over here on
the left we have our
low density planting on the right high
density direct seeded so spacing usually
around one and a half feet by two and a
half feet
and we have roughly eleven thousand six
hundred plants per acre in this
situation
um and you know generally this is direct
seeded with a tractor pushed behind
cedar and irrigation
happens with a sprinkler or furrow
irrigation
okay so just a little bit of background
on direct seeding direct seeding enables
mechanized planting maintenance and
harvest of large acreage which enables
one person to do more per acre on their
farm as long as they have the proper
equipment
um you're able to avoid transplant shock
in auto flowers so water flowers are
really sensitive to any sort of root
disturbance and that can cause them to
be
additionally
stunted
decrease use of plastic you can't use
plastic in this sort of
situation so if you're
concerned about sustainability you're
immediately eliminating
that in your production system
um some cautions weed management is very
intensive until canopy closure occurs
and within some of the autoflower
cultivars canopy closure will not occur
at all
um and additionally establishment can be
quite difficult in wet years and dry
yours require you to be really on top of
your irrigation to get an even stand
so in 2020 in conjunction with oregon
state we hosted
a direct seated field trial at bluegrass
lane
and we had four full season and five
autoflower cultivars and we planted
those uh individuals on june 30th and we
harvested september through
august through september so you can see
uh just a list of the cultivars we used
and their day link sensitivity is right
here in this table
so we direct seeded our plants our seeds
at a quarter of an inch deep
and we planted one seed every five
inches with the polyplanter junior which
is this push behind cedar that you're
seeing right here we had 30 inches
between our rows and we thinned our auto
flowers to one plant per foot and we
send our full season uh plants to one
plant for every foot and a half
and we did that thinning once the plants
had roughly three sets of true leaves
and you can see an unthinned row here
and then grow right here down to about
one uh down to then to one uh plant for
every foot and a half here so
so final percent emergence so um prior
to thinning we counted the number of
plants in a row to determine the final
percent emergence this is the percentage
of plants that successfully germinated
and established themselves as you can
see our numbers are relatively low
ranging from around 30 to 50 percent
so some potential causes of low numbers
are sibling buggle diseases or beverage
by insects or animals like rabbits or
deer
birds eating seed right after planting
planting improperly cleaned seed
and having an incorrect planting
planting depth
so it's important to keep these losses
in mind if you are a producer because
really you saw that we overseeded by
like three times the amount of seed that
we needed in some cases so this really
justifies the need for
uh overseas seeding by a lot and uh this
is tough for some producers because the
price of seed is so high they can't
really justify spending so much money on
seed so it's just something to keep in
mind
it's really necessary for to establish a
successful stand
okay so at flowering time we rated plant
shape to get an idea of the overall
plant architecture within a cultivar
and so just really quickly plant form
can be influenced by genetics and
environment and it gives an idea of the
level of segregation for
um
within a cultivar so if a pla if a
cultivar is segregating heavily for form
perhaps it's also segregating for other
traits like
leaf color or cannabinoid chemotype etc
so additionally some
shapes are thought to possibly be better
for a mechanized harvest we're not
exactly sure which ones those are yet
but it's thought that columnar pure
middle shapes feed better onto a
stripper header than a candelabra strip
shape
um so over here you see our columnar
plant
it's very tall and narrow it has strong
apical dominance and limited branching
our pyramidal shape has a strong central
leader and some branching down here on
the bottom in our candelabra has weak
apical dominance and extreme side
branching
so just as an example over here on in
this plot it's highly uniform you see
that for the most part all the plants
are pure middle
and over here on the right this plot is
segregating for shape we have a mix of a
pure middle shape and a columnar shape
okay so overall you can see that most
cultivars are heavily segregating for
form
um and white and pipeline seem to be the
most uniform pipelines mostly columnar
white is mostly pyramidal
and auto cvg green dream and rogue are
the least uniform cultivars so just
something keep in mind when selecting
your cold bars this might give some
insight
into the overall stability of the
cultivar
so after harvest we dried our plants and
stripped off the floral components and
we took their weight and so this graph
is depicting the total gear yield per
acre for each cultivar in pound
and it is corrected for planting density
and seedling emergence um so as you can
see auto cbd
is the lowest yielding at roughly 1500
pounds per acre and at the end of the
day when you come down to like what is
the yield for a single plant it's very
low it's one tenth of a pound per plant
and a white is the highest at roughly 3
800 pounds per acre and that comes out
still quite well to around a third of a
pound per plant it's important to keep
in mind that since these plants are so
close together they're spending a lot of
time building stem components and
they're only really producing floral
biomass on the very tips where they're
getting a lot of light and it turns into
the canopy
so an additional note here is that
autoflowers are generally lower yielding
than full season plants
um so yeah just something to keep in
mind
so direct seeding just a quick
cautionary tale we attempted to recreate
this trial this past year but as some of
you may know
it was an extremely wet year and uh
unfortunately this trial washed out we
were unable to replant so if you're
interested in direct seeding just be
wary of the fact that this could happen
to you
all right moving on into high tunnels so
why might someone choose to grow on a
high tunnel
so a high tunnel enables the producer to
extend their growing season roughly from
may through october
there's a potential for yield benefit
which we're exploring right now
and there's potential for multiple
cycles of hemp in the high tunnel per
year
which we also explore and some data i'm
going to show you guys right now and
additionally it just allows producers to
diversify their production within their
own hardships
so in 2021 uh we conducted a trial as
part of a larger new york farm viability
institute funded trial um to determine
if double cropping in higher tunnels is
a very viable strategy so we planted
three full season and three autoflower
cultivars in the high tunnels and we
hosted a high tunnel in geneva at the
experiment station and also in cortland
at main street farm so thank you main
street farms for the use of your high
tunnel
so we did we decided to start our plants
in rock wool our compressed soil blocks
to avoid uh irritating the autoflowers
roots like i said earlier they're very
susceptible to becoming stunted if
anything happens to their roots
and then we stagger we planted into a
staggered double row design
and uh we planted our otter flowers at
one plant per foot
this way
and our full season at one plant for
every two feet that same way and there
were roughly two feet in between the
stagger
uh plants
and as you can see we had we just laid
down some
landscape fabric between rows and then
we used drift irrigation
so um after harvest we stripped and
weighed floral biomass the gray boxes
are results with geneva the yellow are
for
portland
and the yield was generally higher in
portland out of flower yield range from
one ounce all the way to two ounces
and on average and full season yield
range from one ounce to five ounces per
plant
uh so just some takeaways here it's very
difficult to get the timing down so that
the full season plants
are transplanted well before they reach
their critical night length which is
their signal to flower
um and so you have to be really on top
of your scheduling when it comes to
you know when you're going to start your
transplants that are immediately
following your auto flowers and be sure
to get your autoflowers in early enough
um so that they're mature in time
um and it might be useful to be sure to
use a very late flowering cultivar
in the high tunnel
um when it comes to the full season
plants
and
you know honestly i would like to repeat
this trial at some point with earlier
planting dates and just knowing what i
know now about scheduling transplants i
think we might get some difficult
different results
so we had
two cultivars that were both direct
seeded and in the high tunnel and as you
can see
generally yield was much higher in the
direct seeded
in the direct seeded plantings so this
really just emphasizes the importance of
not disturbing the autoflowers roots
and it suggests that it might be a good
idea to direct seed into the high tunnel
with a poly planter just to avoid the
need for transplanting in the first
place
so moving on um
this past year we noticed a lot of
powdery mildew in our high tunnels
so as ali uh just went over it's caused
by the ask my seat uh in the glove and
the my seats family
and it is a persistent problem in low
airflow high humidity environments like
high tunnels
and so in 2022 we planned a silicon
application trial uh because this has
proven to uh that because soil based
applications have proven to be really
effective in pumpkins and wheat
and so we want to see if this is the
case for him and it might enable growers
to control their powder and they'll do
without having to spray
and so with that i would just really
like to thank um
janice at cornell cooperative extension
for all of her help in the high tunnel
dr jeff steiner for his help
in procuring seats for the eoh trial the
vines lab for their help
main street farms for their high tunnel
are seed donors over here on the right
side
and like to thank oregon state the farm
viability institute empire state
development ag markets and usda for
funding so with that i'll take any
questions
anybody got oh i see some clapping from
heather yay
um
i have a question so on your weights
for
uh flour
mass
is that wet weight or dry weight that's
a dry weight okay yep
because that can make a big difference
when you're talking about an ounce or
two that could be serious
definitely
and
something about oh the silicone
so chris is still on here too so you
spray it on the soil and then the
the spores can't get up and get on the
plant how does it work yeah the idea is
that you
drench the area or incorporate it into
the soil and uh the plant takes it into
the leaves and it inhibits the ability
of really powdery mildew to
reproduce on the leaves
cool or establish itself yeah
yeah it'll be exciting to see how all
that works uh with a colleague was
telling us that that's what they do in
the greenhouse but
they have to put more
silica in
ever for new growth
right yeah that's what he was saying so
i i think it's a cool study that
savannah will be doing
yeah we'll see how it goes
that sounds interesting any other
questions the still matrix that we that
ally put on was uh fully applied so it's
a it's a different idea right that's why
i wasn't because the last slide was
something else and so
okay
hello thank you all for coming i'm dr
carlin buckler an associate professor of
practice in the school of integrated
plant science at cornell i lead the hemp
master professional studies program and
i'm so glad to talk to you about this
unique opportunity
i started out as a maze geneticist over
30 years ago and as many of you know
hemp or cannabis
is not corn or wheat or apples or field
grains cannabis presents many unique
opportunities as well as threats and for
science too
cannabis uh has been in in front of us
for thousands of years but even as the
green revolution and the advent of
genetics and genomics marched on
we have only in the last several years
been able to use modern plant science to
study this plant that humans have been
using for millennium
cornell university plant science has
been at the forefront of this research
in hemp
and this program allows for a myriad of
paths for students to understand this
plant and what it can and cannot do
as well as how to be successful in the
industry at large
so what is the hemp masters study this
is a one-year intensive program
specifically designed to prepare those
who are interested in the production
processing and or business of hemp to
have a broad-based experience of the
industry as well as a way to become
competent in a specific area of the
industry
courses and projects cover everything
from genetics genomics production
processing disease and pest issues
controlled environments and warehouse
agriculture
whether you're interested in growing for
flower hurt or bad or best
specific aspects of the industry or
maybe someday you want to be your own
ceo or c c o o um in your own home
business
either way we've got you covered from
seed to sales
so let's look at some of the the faculty
who are involved in the mps program
dr larry smart has been leading
cornell's hemp research and extension
team
and has initiated a long-term breeding
and genomic program to develop new hemp
cultivars for new york state
dr smart also teaches courses on plant
genetics and genomics
dr chris smart focuses on managing the
management of disease and host pathogen
interactions in hemp
dr neil matson specializes in greenhouse
and controlled environment agriculture
tony de tomaso studies sustainable
agriculture as well as soil and pest
management
and heather grabbed teaches the
production and processing courses and
let's look into those so those are
similar to the
master's program
so uh dr grab teaches the hemp
production systems and this course will
provide students with
knowledge of different hemp production
systems for fiber grain and cannabinoids
students will gain an understanding of
field controlled environment greenhouse
and high tunnel production systems
topics covered will include hemp
physiology agronomy cultivation seed
science nutrition and fertility harvest
methods and post harvest storage
while this course cannot provide
students with a thorough understanding
of all of the intricacies of hemp
production it is intended to provide a
survey of approaches and techniques that
are used in the production of hemp grain
fiber and cannabinoids
and the hemp processing system excuse me
of course
uh covers the principles and best
practices to create a diverse array of
food extracts and fiber products from
hemp lecturers will describe key
products and production practices
highlight how hemp
products compare to those pro produced
from other materials and discussion
sections will help review scientific
studies relevant to industrial hemp
products and processing and provide
opportunities to interact with key
industry leaders
lab sections will give participants
hands-on experience using a broad array
of analytical and processing equipment
instead students are giving flexibility
to
tailor some course components towards
their own interests as well
this is a plant science overview course
that i teach cannabis biology society
and industry
and the mps students take this in their
first semester
lectures from cornell and from around
the u.s come to the class
and talk about their path to where they
are now and their expertise from
propagation to product but also about
law
policy
business best practices
diversity equity inclusion issues state
and federal regulations pharmacology
veterinary medicine yes that's a thing
and much much more
all of which allows students to explore
every aspect of the industry
and this is one of the reasons the end
this mps program is so good
yes the plant science here is world
class but cornell is also home to the
johnson school of business one of the
best business schools in the in the
country
as well as the dyson school of economics
and management the cornell law school
and many others where you can take
classes as part of your program
many of the speakers who come to uh talk
in my class are not only some of the
most successful people in the business
but
are also graduates from cornell
so
um each ca each each student in the hemp
mps program does a capstone project uh
for their masters of professional
studies that reflects their goals and
interests in hemp field
using your mentors and other faculty and
staff students will write a thesis
describing the project in full
so here's a couple of examples of what
other graduates for the from the hemp
mps program have done
one student came to the program wanting
to learn hemp farming so they could use
their family farm in upstate new york
for hemp production but
after being introduced to folks at
cornell cooperative extension they
decided to help with a survey cce was
doing to find out what kinds of
resources
farmers want to facilitate their
knowledge and needs for farming hemp
the student did a wonderful job working
with cce on on this development and
learned much about understand the
understanding of obstacles that farmers
have hemp face
another student looked at the
misinformation regarding the value
proposition for some farming of hemp
they looked at many of the standard
assumptions of production and research
the research the viability of various
outcomes finding that some were not
quite so viable
and another looked at cold tolerance and
in specific cultivars of hemp that may
help mitigate some ramifications of
climate change
but the bottom line really is that the
choice is yours in this program to delve
deep into what you are interested in for
your final
project
so again uh
really happy to talk to you about this
please come join us if you have any
questions please don't hesitate to email
me
and again i thank you very much for your
time
mary i can also uh chime in with uh we
will be soon this month uh putting out a
job advertisement for to hire someone to
put much of this content online as
certificate programs
so that will be
enhancing our educational program as
well
yeah
actually yeah i do i have a question um
i've been asked by people um whether
these online courses are available but
for everyone and if so what are the
prerequisites and requirements for them
to take these courses
uh my understanding is that the only
course that's currently online is the
hemp reading and genetics
the other courses aren't we haven't even
hired the person that will be working to
put them online yet
um so so
that's in the very infancy
for the
hemp breeding and genetics
um
i actually i
i don't know i think they are open to
everyone but there is a charge
it's not free access
there is on
financial charge
and how about prerequisites
uh to my knowledge there are none
but again i haven't i haven't taken any
and i think
yeah i don't i don't know uh when we
develop the new courses if you know in
order to do the fifth one will you need
the information in the first second and
third or not
uh since since we haven't built them yet
it's too early to say
any other questions from anybody
i will just add a plugin for the growers
and industry members who are in the
audience today
that we are always really excited about
partnering with people from the industry
to help students to develop their
capstone projects so feel free to reach
out if that's of interest
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu